let's go to what happened yesterday
there's plenty on this we got a few
other stories i want to touch up on as
well and we've got 31 minutes left 32
minutes left so yesterday what really
happened yesterday let me tell you the
different stories that i heard
one of the stories was what that hey
somebody on the back end is uh uh
permanently uh
taking the facebook and instagram code
out i think bar stool sports put it up
some twitter account academy put it up
and some of these other guys put it i
mean these are verified accounts these
are not like regular accounts that they
put it up and that went viral and that
got a lot of you saying maybe facebook
and instagram is permanently gone and
people are texting me what's gonna
happen if this thing's permanently gone
and twitter post a tweet which was
hilarious what did twitter say he says
uh we welcome all of you something like
that kai see if you can find that
twitter tweet
uh uh uh they they capitalized on this a
lot yesterday as they should yeah as
they should they said hello literally
everyone he got 3.2 million likes
773 000 retweets so
so one of them is okay somebody hacked
and they destroyed the code whatever
okay so that's not the case another one
is china was involved okay and because
of what happened 60 minutes and so
china's coming out and saying hey
you guys better you know whatever okay
so that's that part the one that was
very interesting that to me really got
me thinking was the final one there's a
group of people that said facebook did
this
facebook did this to themselves why
would facebook do this to themselves
facebook
went
and cleaned house with everything they
had because of what happened a couple
weeks ago a week ago with apple coming
out and saying we're going to take you
off the platform with facebook and
instagram apple just announced that a
week ago and a week later you come out
and you do this maybe they took it down
and they went
destroyed you know who knows
a bunch of these pages on the back end
and took a bunch of the things out and
some of the stuff that you can actually
go see to clean up their name because it
was down for quite a few hours it wasn't
like six hours it wasn't like 30 minutes
so it could be an internal thing that
happened uh now i don't know if that's
true or not but to think about that
thought with facebook all the scrutiny
they're getting this is what's happening
then another part is the fact that
you know the 60 minutes lady was talking
about what kind of content is being
staying up
another
story was the fact that facebook helped
trump with election and they don't want
facebook to have the kind of power in
the next election because they have so
much power in getting somebody elected
so if there's control on mainstream
media the left's only threat is what
they don't have control over which is
facebook and mark zuckerberg is not a
yes guy mark's not saying yes and they
kind of don't like that mark's not
sitting there saying yes we'll do this
yes we'll do that he's the only one that
said you know we'll see if we're going
to get trump and but we're not
permanently banning trump we're going to
have our team to look at it twitter says
what we're permanently banning trump
right so facebook is a threat
to the left because facebook could help
the opposing party get elected maybe
they want a little bit more control some
want this thing to be more controlled by
the government because if the government
controls facebook it's over so imagine
if the government runs facebook would
you want that so anyways that's some of
the stuff i've heard i'll leave it up to
you guys gerard what do you think
happened yesterday based on some of the
articles you read i don't want to get
crazy in the conspiracies here but i
just i i think uh i think it's very very
the timing of things is very very
curious i it's becoming more and more
difficult for me to to consider
coincidences over the last 18 months to
two years it's you know coincidences
just seem to you know keep
keep piling up into into ways that that
increase power for the for the most
powerful amongst us it's it's amazing
how these coincidences keep keep
funneling into into their win column uh
you know china tightens up political
control of internet giants is a story
that headlines abc news three days ago
they fly
38 38 flight fighter jets over taiwan
yesterday
there's a leak with cnn i would on cnn
about facebook and then facebook goes
down snapchat goes down
um
you know whatsapp goes down six hours
tick tock's fine uh i i don't i don't
i don't see this all as being isolated
instances i see this all as being
somehow interconnected i think that
there are uh political games there are
machinations being played at levels that
that it's hard for normal people to
understand and to comprehend what's
happening on a global scale
i think the world is becoming very very
very small at the top of the pyramid and
i think that there's a lot of people
vying for control for that top and and
we're we're kind of seeing that
trickle-down effect down hit us that
that's what i think happens um and my
biggest takeaway was like while we're
joking and while you know we're all like
looking at our facebook and while we're
like wow this is you know people are
like get outside talk to each other my
whole thing is like man i can't believe
how easy it was to disconnect the world
i can't believe how easy it was to
disconnect everybody you know if they
did that and they took cell service away
what would we do like that's it what
would they what would we do for six
hours what could be done in six hours of
radio silence how how much ground could
be lost
could could could you recover
six hours of radio silence
what what could be taken from you
that that's where my mind went through
my one went through was i am remarkably
under prepared for what i i think is an
increasingly freaking war that's what
i'm saying what could happen in six
hours six hours of radio silence how
much different could the world you come
back to be
and i i felt very helpless in in that
i'm completely and totally underprepared
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]